Okay, Michael.
So
with that, I think we're kind
of done with this lesson.
Those are the three things
that I wanted to mention and
I think we can now go back
to where you left off and
talk about what we have learned,
except I have the pen.
And so
you have to tell me what we've learned.
I don't have to tell you.
>> This is true.
So now when you see the three things,
what were the three things
that you talked about?
>> Your trying to trick me into
telling me what we learned.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah a little bit.
All right, so.
All right.
So when I had the pen, we talked about.
Well two main things,
well the overall topic is the CCC.
>> Right.
>> Which is Comedy Central Committees.
[SOUND]
>> No!
>> Closed caption clowns.
>> No.
>> So, coordinating,
communicating, and coaching.
>> Right.
>> Ha!
>> I think what we learned is that
alliteration can be fun.
>> Well, sure, and in particular,
I talked about two particular models.
One was the DEC POMD VP model.
Which least at least let us define or
ask questions about what it means to
coordinate and communicate optimally
when we've got agents that don't share
a brain but they do share the reward
function so what's good for each one
of them is good for the community.
>> Right.
Shared our distinct brains.
>> I like that.
>> Then we talked about
the inverse reinforcement learning
idea which was that we could actually
use examples of behavior demonstrations
of behavior to infer reward functions
and then once we have those reward
functions we could try to
optimize them in other settings.
>> Yep we go from behaviors to
rewards instead of going from
rewards to behavior.
And that is what makes it inverse.
>> And having those rewards
means that it generalizes to
other settings as well.
>> Right, and I think that a point that
I made on that, when I started taking
over the pen, was that this actually
is a kind of reward shaping,
by getting human beings to give us
hints about what we ought to be doing.
>> Okay, but
in the form of behavior demonstrations.
But in the form of
behavior demonstrations.
And that is a nice little
point worth making,
which is demonstrations
are one way to do coaching.
What were the other ways
we did some coaching?
>> So,
yeah demonstrations is what we did and
then there was this kind
of policy feedback policy.
I guess you called it policy shaping.
>> Right.
>> But it was a sort of idea that you
can get feedback on the actions
being taken by the agent and
that can be incorporated or
combined with other suggestions as well
as what the learner is picking up on.
>> And so between reward shaping,
demonstrations and policy shaping,
we got a nice little set of ways that
human beings can communicate to agents.
So let's see.
I know I did more than this.
There were some examples that I used.
What kind of examples did I use?
>> Well, in the policy shaping setting,
we talked about Pac-Man.
Pac-Man
>> Yeah.
So we learned that Pac-Man is like
the one example you should use
for everything.
>> Sure except for what we did at
the end, end which was drama management.
>> Right,
right we talked about drama management.
And in particular, [LAUGH] yeah.
In particular we introduced TTD-MDPs.
Where TTD MDP has something to
do with trajectories and drama.
>> Targets and stuff.
That's exactly right.
And I think we had a nice
little conversation here,
tying some of these things
back to things we did before.
We actually returned and
brought up again constraints and
options as a way of doing coaching and
communication.
And try to really drive home the point
that there are some human beings and
they think a particular way and
then there are machines and
they think a particular way.
And we should try to move
the machines closer to the humans.
Rather than forcing the humans to come
all the way over to the machines.
>> Yeah I like that as a philosophy.
>> And
that's really what I think is important.
Yeah that's a good philosophy.
Well I think that covers
everything Michael.
>> Nice.
>> I feel pretty good about that.
Nice, so does this mean we're done?
I think this means we're done
with the class, kind of.
>> Really?
So maybe we should do some kind of
wrap up to see how
everything ties together.
>> Yeah, let's do that.
That way I don't have to say goodbye,
why don't you come down to Atlanta and
maybe we can record some stuff together.
>> Great I will have done that.
>> Perfect.
Or is it perfect or
is that the past perfect poo perfect.
>> Poo perfect.
>> Yes the perfect good perfect.
Okay Michael,
well I will see you in Atlanta soon.
>> Bye Charles.
>> Bye.